If you didn't watch the presidential debate,
we'll tell you in two minutes what happened.
Block one education and health.
In health care Xóchil Gálvez used a digital card with the
medical history of patients so that they can be treated
in public or private hospitals and buy medicines.
Claudia Sheinbaum developed Welfare Pharmacies to distribute
medicines so that medical personnel are better prepared.
Jorge Maynes developed a pedagogical system focused on children that
is not only financed by businessmen but also by the state.
In education Xóchitl Gálvez intends to return schools and full-time
stays to raise teachers' salaries and to be better prepared.
Sheinbaum would build new public universities such as those created
when she was head of government of Mexico City and would follow
up on the model known as the new inclusive school.
Maines would make alliances with private universities and strengthen
public universities in addition to rebuilding existing schools.
Block two transparency and fight corruption.
Maines proposes that companies that have contracts with the government
be subject to the same laws as public servants.
Rochel wants to reduce direct bids,
strengthen Inai and ensure that most of the procedures are digital.
Shaymond would create the National Anti-Corruption Agency,
a project he claims was created with a group of experts.
Touch three non-discrimination vulnerable groups and violence against women.
Regarding gender violence,
Xóchil seeks to attend to 100 percent of emergency calls and provide
financial support to the women victims.
Claudia wants to bring the asterisk 7 6 5 emergency line to the national level
and the law to remove the aggressors from their homes to the federal level.
Maynes affirmed that the feminist movement is the most important
of our time and proposes a national care system.
Xóchil Gálvez would protect the human rights of migrants
and withdraw military forces from the southern border.
Claudia Sheinbaum proposes to have more support programs in
Central America so that people do not have to migrate.
Maines also wants to accompany migrants as they pass through Mexico
and would defend them from the likes of Donald Trump.
This is the first debate of three Next year is April 28 and
will be about economic inequality and climate change.
What should they propose?